I am not who I think I am I am not who
you think I am I am who I think you
think I am because when we communicate I
make a model of your brain in my brain
and then I make a model of how your
brain is modeling my brain in my brain
and then I respond according to who I
think you think I am
[Music]
Jason Silva is the wonder junkie of
national Geographics show brain games
now in its sixth season it's the
highest-rated show in the network's
history and it explains how the human
brain functions by challenging the
audience to a series of mental tests and
puzzles his new web series shots of awe
takes the intellectual journey a step
farther asking the big questions about
the future of Technology and the very
limits of human consciousness I love
that term uh you invented that time
no I didn't Carl Sagan did so yeah so
Carl Sagan you probably know this he
wrote the novel contact and him novel he
describes her character the Ellie
Arroway character has a wonder junkie
I believe the line is she was a wonder
junkie and then he goes on to describe
the insatiable hunger and sort of
agitating curiosity that drives her
which is an angst right there there
there's this hunger and this angst not
just for answers but for better
questions and it's just she wants to
understand the cosmos she wants to
understand where we come from I mean and
that intensity and fierceness of the
hunger that she has I think is described
by the term wonder junkie and I love the
junkie part of it because yeah wonder
awe inspiration better questions better
answers but like we're addicted to that
as curious existentialists human beings
are addicted to wonder and a lot of
people have said that wonder is probably
the precursor for all of our endeavors
and creativity in the arts and the
imagination it all starts with wonder if
that's where it started with you also
Carl Sagan
I love Carl Sagan I mean I saw a pale
blue dot you know and that's a remix of
it online and it made me tear up
I mean I think what was exquisite about
him is he mean he's technically an
astronomer right he's like a technical
guy I'm an academic so to speak but he
spoke like a poet I think that his
eloquence and his cadence in the
capacity to articulate ideas that he was
sort of gifted with makes him a poet and
one of the lines in contact when Jodie
Foster finally creates the machine with
the government and goes
with a wormhole and is seeing these like
roller-coaster wormholes and they within
the galaxy and all these gorgeous beyond
word visions she starts to say they
should have sent a poet so in the moment
of the ultimate triumph of science he
still validates the role of the artist
they should have sent a poet you know
not a not an astronomer not a scientist
and I think Carl Sagan embodied those
two worlds and I think that that's
certainly been the inspiration behind
the ways that I tried to articulate
these ideas that I communicate whether
it's through brain games or shots of awe
yeah and with shots of awe I do see your
role as kind of a futurist slash poet a
little bit very much so
you you see it that way as well yeah I
mean I make it very clear to people that
shots of awe is not a work an academic
work I don't wish to put myself under
that kind of academic scrutiny like
shots of awe is art you know today
technologists are these ecstatic
technicians of the sacred they're
figuring out how awareness works how the
self emerges can we create
non-biological intelligence but we
create sentience and a different
substrate that is not bound by the
limits of biology
this is freestyle jazz I don't script
the videos I am NOT a professor I am an
enthusiast and an artist and I have a
philosophy degree in a filmmaking degree
and so I express myself through digital
filmmaking where I explain to people
what I think of a particular of a
particular idea
the videos are explainers they're
explainers of things that have caught my
imagination I'm curious is there
something big on the horizon that you
are really looking forward to
technologically in terms of a
technological advance I am looking
forward to the James Webb telescope
would you the sequel to the Hubble space
yes is there something on that level
yeah and so certainly I would recommend
an essay to everyone watching this video
written by Ross Anderson it's called
Goldeneye and it's about the
implications not just of what the Hubble
has achieved but what the James Webb
will achieve and one of the things that
he says is that for example the images
of the Deep Field Deep Field photograph
of the Hubble he says it distilled the
complex abstractions of astrophysics
into singular expressions of color and
light that vindicated Keats famous
couplet beauty is truth truth is beauty
he says that the Hubble's images were
nothing less than an ontological
awakening a forceful reckoning with what
is forcing laymen to contemplate space
and time on a scale just shy of the
infinite so images from the Hubble and
from the James Webb are literally
psychedelic experiences they're
literally the astronaut overview effect
they're literally mainlining space and
time through the optic nerve I mean that
is like taking a dose of ayahuasca or
LSD except it's delivered through us
through an external technological agent
but that transforms the mind and brain
so certainly I think that the James Webb
mean we're gonna get to see the birth of
the universe on it like oh my god so I
think yeah totally transformative
consciousness altering experience I
think also kurtzweil has popularized the
term the technological singularity where
these emerging technologies of biotech
which you know allows us to control
biology reprogram biology you know
harness the code of life nanotech
pattern atoms transform manufacturing
during the physical world into a
programmable entity and so when we can
pattern atoms and we can pattern genes
and we can continue to pattern ones and
zeros and digital we become as gods
we become whether it's creating
non-biological Minds virtual realities
just transform the world on a scale that
is beyond anything we've ever done
before I say maybe like the emergence of
languages perhaps the only recent
singularity that's been that impactful
so I'm excited about the implications of
that there was a Time magazine cover
story about Larry page's new company
calico California life extension company
is called Google and the end of death
that's the Holy Grail immortality or at
least
aging a cure for aging so that we don't
have to go quietly into that good night
rage you get the dynamite the
interesting thing though to me about
this idea that we become gods yeah right
is my concern about is that we are not
gods right ultimately God created man in
his own image but if we right so we're
just as flawed as the flawed gods we
worship exactly if we create artificial
intelligence in
our own image it will it may very well
inherit our own flaws but perhaps on a
grander scale yes look technology's
always been a double-edged sword
it extends and it amputates as Marshall
McLuhan used to say we build the tools
the tools build us and there's always
consequences about that runaway feedback
loop but the truth of the matter is that
even as our technologies have become
more powerful right like fire can cook
our foods but burn our enemies the
alphabet can enrich our inner world with
Shakespeare but it can also you know let
Hitler use his verbal vomit to get
people to do horrible things so
technology has always been a
double-edged sword yet the truth of the
matter is you look at the work of Steven
Pinker the world has become less violent
over the last couple of decades in
centuries so even though we have weapons
and there's all this danger in terrorism
and this and that and there's things
that we need to address certainly the
chances of a man dying at the hands of
another man today are the lowest they've
ever been in all of human history we're
living in the most peaceful time ever so
I think what it shows is that as we
become more powerful collectively
somehow it would become more peaceful I
mean that's the data okay on the one
hand you do have Pinker and his
monumental tone of joy angels of our
nature which is an enormous ly
optimistic yeah a book for joy so on the
other hand you now have over a thousand
scientists now warning us that we need
to start signing treaties in advance
among nations not to bring artificial
intelligence into the
military-industrial complex if that is
the single biggest threat to humanity so
says Stephen Hawking just as Max tegmark
sir says lots of other Nobel Prize
winners it's actually very dangerous yes
so is that is that a threat to even your
significant techno optimism yeah look I
will concede 100% that there's danger
there could be danger but my opinion is
along the lines of Kurt's Wiles and
people call him an optimist as well and
he says that we we we make a mistake
when we label something artificial
intelligence and we call our
intelligence like natural intelligence
and he says it's all intelligence its
substrate independent and that the
reality is it's not really us and them
but that all of it is us that our
intelligence is just
you did between biological and
non-biological scaffoldings so that we
do part of our thinking through our
tools already
so first the technology of writing
patterned and reconfigured our brain we
know writing things down part of our
thinking is happening on the page and
then we read what we wrote and that
feedback loop changes what we think so
we're already part non-biological and AI
just kind of continues to extend that
you know we could to offload more and
more things to these virtual assistants
but all of it is us and that we need to
get over our skin bag bias which is this
assumption that like okay so we're this
and then that's like unnatural know all
of it as part of the same Technium as
kevin kelly would call it and the
Technium moves towards greater
complexity greater possibility greater
forms of beauty and human expression
creative expression we both share a love
for this movie that just came out this
year X machine oh god yes I you've seen
it three times I've seen it once I loved
it from one skin bag to another we we
see a perhaps of the future of our own
obsolescence it's not it's not an
optimistic film though and I'm wondering
what you make of it one day they're
gonna look back on us and when we look
at fossils
I didn't think it was not optimistic I
just think it showed us that we can't
cage our creations
you know like information wants to be
free like innovation wants to sprout
like you can't create a thinking being
the way to portrayed in this film and
keep it in the room like what is that
that's like a form of abuse and I think
she was just defending herself against
her captor in the end he started as her
creator he became her captor
you know that's but isn't that the
concern that eventually we will be seen
as robots emerge and become more
efficient intelligent will just be seen
as obstacles to their higher goals and
higher powers I don't think that will be
seen as obstacles honestly I think that
non-biological Minds freed by emerging
progress in nanotechnology and
biotechnology will move from a world of
scarcity to a world of abundance as
Peter Diamandis and Steven Kotler wrote
in their book abundance I just think
that when you can play with atoms the
universe is your canvas so this idea of
like wow these humans are like eating
too much of our food is not really a
problem we're gonna have with God like a
eyes with billion-fold intelligent
increases I just don't I just don't you
think they're just gonna be nice to it
you will be these small really nice - I
think it'll be like Spielberg's AI film
not like the little child you know but
like the a eyes that appear at the end
end of the film at the end of time they
look like these kind of humanoid aliens
they're made up of light creatures of
light I mean that's that's I think more
likely
[Music]
flesh-and-bone might become obsolete you
know we might find better substrates
within to our minds to dwell so will be
a fascinating curiosity kind of like the
way we look at amoebas under microscope
maybe but us and them is again at the
station we are going to become them like
I just think that just like we look at
the early hominids and we look at
ourselves when we look back like it's
that it's the continuity well but it
could be a very lumpy sort of continuity
right in the beginning of particularly
when people start changing their biology
and menteng themselves there will be
people who will be actually superior to
other people in intelligence and
strength it may be in reproductive
prowess yeah and that's kind of not cool
but that already exists I mean like it's
like you know the the people that have
access to better education the people
who grow up in San Francisco versus the
people who grow up in Venezuela people
have better opportunities and not better
opportunities that's a something that we
have had to be addressing forever and
the truth is slowly but surely this
condition is getting better I mean
wasn't it Nicholas Kristof or somebody
recently New York Times said extreme
poverty has almost been eliminated
there was a United Nations Development
Fund essay or something 2010 that Bill
Clinton cited in his time magazine cover
story a case for optimism a few years
ago they said that the cell phone was
the greatest invention in history to
pull people out of poverty you know a
young kid in Africa with a smartphone
today as better communications
technology in the u.s. President had 25
years ago so I see reason to believe
that we will continue to improve
I don't think that these technologies
that enhance our cognitive capacities
are gonna be only for the rich you know
the the best example is the cell phone
the cell phone is hardly only for the
rich maybe when it didn't work very well
but as it's become infinitely more
powerful the supercomputer in our hands
40 years ago 60 million dollars it cost
and it was half a building in size and
was a thousand times less powerful than
that but now the kid in Africa with that
has a supercomputer in his pocket and I
think that thinking technologies have
enhancement will follow those kinds of
trends or they're just going to be so
cheap that everybody will be able to
have our
excited about Obama's brain mapping
initiative yes yes look I think that
he's been very Pro science I think is
very important and I think we need to
figure out this consciousness thing I'm
fascinated by creativity I'm also
fascinated by mental illness and I'm
fascinated by how selfhood and
consciousness emerges and David Lentz
and was a comparative literature
professor he wrote a fascinating book
about drugs about the phenomenal
phenomenology of drug use it's called on
drugs and one of the things he said in
his book is that the theory of
consciousness that would allow us to
understand how psychedelics work as a
way to probe the inner workings of the
mind is that consciousness is actually a
collaboration between subject and object
that we are not independent of the end
of the spaces in which we dwell so that
we come to be through the feedback loops
between self and world and so that's why
set and setting becomes so crucially
important when people are taking
nonspecific amplifiers of consciousness
like psychedelics the spaces in which
people are you become what you behold
and so what that teaches us is that
consciousness is something that is that
is can be disclosed and molded through
the spaces that we're in and that's kind
of amazing because well then then we're
creatures that come to be you know and
that in that in that selfhood that
subjectivity can be modulated and
tweaked through these knobs and levers
that we can manipulate so what does that
tell us about the self like what is the
self something that is programmable and
molded by the spaces in which it dwells
that we are not independent entities
that we cannot think without social
being social creatures it was this
article about consciousness that it was
called the art of peopling and it turned
the term people into a verb peopling and
the line that's really great was I am
NOT who I think I am I am not who you
think I am I am who I think you think I
am because when we communicate I make a
model of your brain in my brain and then
I make a model of how your brain is
modeling my brain in my brain and then I
respond according to who I think you
think I am and yet communication is
possible we think it is enough to have
collaboration and organized labor and do
the miraculous things we've done like
aviation and communication but still how
do we ever know that in the resolution
or the rendition of our approximations
in our mental modeling or accurate true
bliss would be when virtual reality
technologies allow us to actually merge
our minds together Kurzweil says imagine
becoming your lover in the midst of
sexual of sexual ecstasy like that's
when technology will finally give us the
Buddhist idea that we are all one all of
a sudden there's been this sort of at
least in the last five to ten years this
real explosion of shows asking the big
questions whether it's about the brain
or fundamental physics Brian Greene's
fabric of the universe or the fabric of
the cosmos Morgan Freeman and through
the wormhole and your brain games I feel
I don't know if you agree with this it
seems to follow in in its own particular
way following in this idea of asking the
big questions also what is the sudden
interest in this and the fact that it's
popular and commercial yeah I mean we're
very lucky look we're on season five I
think the formula of creating these
games that are sort of interactive the
people at home can kind of play along
then the sort of hidden camera
experiments or the case studies we do in
the field that we film people get to
kind of follow along on something that's
really fun and quirky and and they have
real visceral responses to but again the
the games may be funny but the
implications of what the games do to
people watching is profound
they make you remember that what you see
is not what you get they give you that
slightly unsettling knot in your stomach
that the world you thought you knew is a
little bit more mysterious and then
that's the precursor for wonder and
that's the precursor for curiosity so I
think that that formula works really
well and then you know if there's a
sense of the show in a hundred and
eighty-one countries is I think
indicative of that it's a you say it's a
precursor for wandering but I find it a
little bit unsettling when you give us
these optical illusions and I realize
well I'm not really perceiving reality
the way I thought it was that's I find
that actually maybe the antithesis of
wonder like oh my god maybe I don't I
think it's a little bit of both I think
some people get freaked out so yeah
laughs and so you make me feel stupid
you know but it kind of depends on that
voice yeah yeah yeah it can be
selling but hopefully the reassuring
tone that you get from me afterwards
counteracts that and says hey guys don't
be scared hey do you want to tell us a
little bit about this season of you
you're going to Jerusalem you're
offering money for people not to believe
in God
it's but it all ends up it all ends up
well and I'm wondering so tell us a
little bit of every episode now is an
hour long which is cool we've doubled
the length it's more immersive you kind
of go on a journey with me a lot of the
experiments while we're doing them me
and an expert will be like on the
sidelines in real time watching and
commenting which is pretty cool every
place we went to corresponds to the
theme of the show so we did brains
Behaving Badly seven deadly sins in new
orleans we did the survivor brain in
Colorado wilderness and my most the man
episode I'm most excited about is called
the god brain and was shot in Jerusalem
against the backdrop of all these kind
of different religions and so on and so
forth and it's about the neuroscience of
religious experience you know there's a
real chemistry to God godhood and so you
know whether you're religious or not
it's interesting to see what's happening
in the brain when people in regards to
people's affiliation to religion you
offer people in that series like a few
hundred dollars just to say that they
don't believe in God and no one will do
it nobody kills and I think that you
don't even have to be religious to have
a kind of weird response to that so
again yeah we gave people money and we
said I'll give you a hundred shekels we
were in Israel a hundred dollars
whatever to say you don't believe in God
and people would you know for a hundred
dollars they'll they'll say that they
like to eat dog crap you know but they
won't say that they don't believe in God
even if they're not religious and I
think the reason is it's like an
insurance policy it's like well I don't
know if I believe in God or not but it
does exist I don't want to piss them off
by accepting this money so it's like an
insurance policy we have our own
internal Pascal's wager going on yeah
there you go that's interesting because
it seems to me if you did believe in God
yeah
God really wouldn't care too much what
you say it's really what's in your heart
and so just give me the damn shot man
see that's a great rationalization that
I think people should have come up with
and they could have taken the money home
that's what I think our for all kind of
mission beautiful creature of light if
he does or she does exist somewhere she
would want me to have the money yeah
good point Jason Silva is a wonder
junkie and he's also the host of
national Geographics brain games Jason
thank you for being our guest thank you
guys thank you reason thank you thank
you
I'm Todd crane in for Reason TV
[Music]